vous avez quand même des personnes des
rencontres
voilà qui qui qui ont changé aussi
votre façon de penser ou avec des des
rencontres vraiment vous étiez des amis
je sais pas là bas parmi les codétenus
ont des amis non c'est parce que j'étais
pas là pour faire des amis non mais
c'était pas la peine de faire des
ennemis non plus mais à un moment il ya
des cultes a des liens qui se créent oui
oui oui il y a eu quelques ya eu
quelques beaux moments où dur moment je
pense y un îlien des québécois de rien
qui m'a enseigné l'espagnol et à qui
j'enseigne le français
qui a perdu son frère
pendant que
pendant son acoustique incarcération et
moi je pensais à mon frère et je me
faisais mais si je perdais mon frère
pendant mon incarcération mais ça serait
là ce serait vraiment vraiment la france
donc ça c'était un moment du enfin dur
pour lui mais aussi
vu j'avais un peu lié d'amitié avec lui
on avait partagé quelques quelques
quelques quelques rires même si c'était
des rires forcés pour la plupart du
temps
ça m'a fait de la peine pour lui et je
me disais mais voilà ça pourrait être si
cette arrivée à toi mais alors là ça
serait la fin de la fin c'était quoi les
veaux journée en prison en turquie
au début au milieu ou la fin de mon
incarcération parce que ça fait quatre
enfants 86 a répondu le le voilà la
journée type au début c'est quoi vous
je me gavais de somnifères pour essayer
de dormir
tous voulaient en fait vous lui
demandiez c'est différent alors il y
avait alors quand on est avec les
étrangers il y avait quelques étrangers
qui vivent est arrivé beaucoup de
syriens ou irakiens qui vivait en
turquie depuis longtemps donc qui
connaissait le turc dont qu'ils
écrivaient les pétitions enfin l'effet
fallait faire des pétitions pour tous
aux autorités pénitentiaires pour
réclamer un traitement médicamenteux ou
ou d une visite pour aller voir le
directeur ou pour
pour un parloir ou points 2
le droit au téléphone enfin ou
d'affaires les dix minutes de téléphone
hebdomadaire que qu'on a qu'on avait et
donc je sais plus où j'étais on était
sur les somnifères les somnifères donc
oui je prenais des doses des doses de 2e
pas le de somnifères pour pour m'abrutir
quoi pour eux pour me
anesthésier le cerveau me dit c'est pas
possible c'est un moment ou un autre ça
va s'arrêter ça veut pas ça peut pas
continuer comme ça en entendant bien
longtemps et donc il y avait c'est donc
c'est somnifères que je prenais et puis
à part après mon agression il y avait un
détenu un des co détenus qui m'a dit
fabien garde toujours un couteau sous
son oreiller parce qu'on sait jamais été
en prison et donc après mon agression
j'ai gardé et j'avais toujours un
couteau sous mon oreiller et si vous
voulez quand vous pas moi je bouge
beaucoup pendant la nuit quand vous
mettez votre main sous un oreiller et
vous vous réalisez qu'il ya un couteau
enfin vous toutes les nuits ça
recommence mais je me suis dit mais
c'est juste pas possible c'est c'est ma
vie est devenue un enfer mais pire qu'un
enfer pire qu'un film un mauvais film de
2,2 de policiers ou de là un film
d'horreur vous avez pensé à l'utiliser
un jour n'y avait jamais eu un moment où
vous aimez le vieux oui mais j'aurais
même pas su comment l'utiliser en fait
j'ai pensé il ya eu des moments où on a
dit ça va alors je me barricader alors
après avoir passé un certain temps en
prison je me barricader dans ces délits
se superposent et je me barricader avec
des couvertures en fait pour pour eux
savoir qu'ils rentraient dans la cellule
je faisais des micro trous dans la dans
la couverture parce que quand vous êtes
dans l'intérieur du lit vous voyez vous
avez un angle de vision que la personne
n'a pas quand elle viendra dans la dans
la pièce si vous voulez d'accord donc et
et moi j'ai insulté je suis très light
leopard je je
jg je suis un dormeur léger bref y
compris car l'acte est
donc
une mouche qui vole me réveilles tu
attends donc quand j'entendais le moins
brute de ba ba je me réveillais je
regardais city venait dans la chambre en
fait et donc je prenais mon couteau si
je me faisait agresser je pourrais
peut-être menacer la personne n'est
j'aurais pas su comment comment utiliser
un couteau je sais pas je sais pas te
faire mal de mal à un animal alors
imaginez une personne un humain